working hard is quite a controversial
Topic in 2023 I'm going to say some
stuff that's going to bother some people
I work all the time I have no Hobbies
besides working out that's it that's all
I do and I work until I can't work and
then I usually bend some sort of
Television comma and that's okay they're
like that's not healthy I'm like Define
healthy I do as much as I can of the
thing that I want to do with every
minute of my day why do you want me to
do something that I would prefer to do
less the same degree they cannot work it
off doesn't affect me I'm a big big
advocate for destroying should the word
you should go to school you should get a
degree you should do this job you should
marry her there's all these shoulds that
other people tell us it's like should
what there is no do what you want
to do